kink visibility is a reminder that any
person can and should
shamelessly explore what brings joy and
excitement
i mean they're literally talking about
children watching kink parades
i'm pretty sure that the line from their
pedophilia is real thin
well today marks the first day of
non-pride month which means that all of
the corporate logos go back to normal
all the corporations stop with their
woke virtue signaling
and uh they're not expected to keep up
with the world virtue signaling so
you know i guess that pride is over and
we're back to regular life is the way
that this this nonsense works
uh but not before the worst column of
pride month came out in the washington
post
it's by a person named lauren rowello a
writer who lives in the philadelphia
area
okay so this this person wrote a piece
in the washington post titled yes
kink belongs at pride and i want my kids
to see it
now i tend to be pretty libertarian
about things right when
i don't think the government should
really be in the business of compulsion
unless somebody is hurting somebody else
and this starts to get dicey when you're
talking about children
there is a battle that is brewing about
the future of our nation's kids
and it is unavoidable it is not
avoidable there is no libertarian
solution to it
okay the libertarian solution typically
which is let everybody do whatever it is
that they want
as long as they're not hurting anybody
else that libertarian argument ceases to
apply when you're talking about the
impact
on children who do not have the power of
consent do not have fully rational
characteristics
are not capable of making decisions then
we as a society
have to decide what the rules of the
road are going to be and this has come
up in the context of for example
critical race theory recently
where the right has said quite correctly
that children should not be
indoctrinated with the nonsense of
critical race theory which suggests
that racially essential characteristics
determine your value
and your perspective on matters of
politics and whether you have a chance
of success in the united states
kids should not be indoctrinated with
that it's a violation
of children's ability to thrive and it
is in fact
a form of emotional and intellectual
child abuse
to teach kids that they are victimizers
or the victimized
okay so when it comes to kids we all do
have a fairly large say
in what the societal standard should be
because again there's a non-consenting
party who's now part of this bargain
the same thing holds true when it comes
to social policy so
the left has decided and this is again i
think an unavoidable battle that is
going to come to your town it is going
to come to your state
it's going to come to your household and
the unavoidable battle is you have a
group of people on the left
and they suggest that if you raise your
child in a traditional manner
if you raise your child to believe that
a traditional family structure is better
okay that a man and a woman raising a
child is better than a man and a man or
a woman and a woman
if you believe that men and women exist
and that these are not malleable
categories
and that a man cannot become a woman and
that if a child suffers from gender
dysphoria
you should participate in for example
watchful waiting
right you you should simply wait to see
how things develop
you should not give in to the delusion
that your child actually is a member of
the opposite gender
the left believes if you do that that's
a form of child abuse and cps should
arrive at your door
don lemon on cnn literally yesterday
said that he believes
only the state should be involved in
adoption decisions presumably because he
likes
the state's perspective when it comes to
these matters of social politics
and he thinks that churches should be
taken completely out of the business of
adoption
not because he doesn't like quote
unquote churches per se but because he
doesn't like the perspective of churches
which may adopt out to traditional
father mother families
and not to male male families female
female families
single dads or single moms right so
that is one perspective on the raising
of children is that the social left
ought to win
and then there's the perspective from
the right which is that children's
innocence when it comes to matters of
sex
ought to be preserved that you are fully
not only justified but doing a good in
teaching your child traditional sexual
values
that teaching your child for example
that getting married to a member of the
opposite sex and producing natural born
children is more likely to produce
happiness
that if you teach your kid that you're
doing something good for them and that
if you indoctrinate them
into confusion and more importantly if
you sexualize children at a very young
age you are doing grave harm
not only to their psyche but also to
their emotional state
that perspective means that there will
have to be some protection for children
and these two
wildly varying perspectives are now
coming to a head and they're in direct
conflict and so
this column from the washington post is
indicative of that conflict
and it should awaken people who are sort
of softly in the middle
you know the silent middle that this
battle is is going
it is going to happen and the folks who
claim that they just want to live and
let live perspective
on how people raise their kids they're
mostly lying it really is not true
okay because the way that identity works
in the united states now
is based on emotivism identity is rooted
in the notion that if i deny
your perspective on your own identity
then i have participated in a harm
against you and i must be stopped
this is why you are seeing for example
an attempt
to to it will come to the united states
by the way you've already seen it in
canada there's an attempt now to go
after parents
on the basis that they are not teaching
their children the state approved
messaging with regard to gender and
sexual orientation
that's going to come to the united
states because the perspective of the
left is you are doing great harm to a
child
if you don't teach their their sort of
polyamorous perspective on how exactly
sexual matters should work if you don't
teach that to children if you don't and
kids in that
and these two world views are clashing
and they're clashing when it comes to
kids
now to this column in the washington
post which is astonishing again this is
printed
in a major one of the two biggest
american newspapers in terms of
influence and impact lauren writing
quote
our family often took the train into
philadelphia but as we rode across the
bridge to attend the city's pride parade
five years ago my wife's leg bounced
with a nervous jitter
she squeezed my hand worried that she
might run into a colleague or be
harassed by a stranger
my wife is trans and wasn't out at the
time so she typically only expressed her
authenticity in the privacy of our home
that morning she wore a green skirt and
light makeup brushing her hair all to
one side
even though we'd attended pride marches
and protests in previous years that they
was our first
celebrating openly as a family it's what
we are talking about now is a male
female couple in which the male now
identifies as female
okay so number one that is highly likely
to um to confuse children
okay that in and of itself okay but
beyond that they're now taking
their kid a small their small children
to a pride parade
in which you are celebrating sexual
activity that's what pride is
okay pride is not a mere question of
family structure it is a celebration of
particular types of sexual activity
because after all if it were just a
celebration of family structure then you
could have two brothers adopting a kid
or a brother and a sister
or a single mom right but that's not
what pride parades typically are about
as people have noted
people who have been to pride parades
and who cover pride parades understand
that pride parades very often
and almost entirely the universality of
pride parades
include sexual components to them right
that
undoubtedly so children should not be at
these things adults want to participate
you can make a libertarian argument
obviously and it's a libertarian
argument which i generally agree which
is this is not
a matter of compulsion however if you're
talking about children now you're
talking about non-consenting people
being put into sexual scenarios for the
pleasure of adults that's the only
reason you're bringing kids to this
thing
so this is what this mother writes when
our children grew tired of marching we
plopped onto a nearby curb
just as we got settled our elementary
schooler pointed in the direction of
oncoming floats
raising an eyebrow at a bare-chested man
in dark sunglasses whose black
suspenders clipped onto a leather thong
the man paused to be spanked playfully
by a partner with a flog
what are they doing my curious kid asked
as our toddler cheered them on
the pair was the first of a few dozen
kingsters who danced down the street
laughing together as they twirled their
hips and batons
some leading companions by leashes at
the time my children were too young to
understand the nuance of the situation
but i told them the truth
that these folks were members of our
community celebrating who they are and
what they like to do see the conflation
of who they are and what they like to do
is always a very interesting
identity driven notion right that who
you are is what you like to do it's the
same thing
it's it's you know there's an argument
to be made that that is not
that immutable characteristics do not
include flogging other men in public on
their on their bottom i mean i think
there
there's a fair notion that for example
if you're making the argument
that that gay rights are similar to to
race rights
um i i i'm spotting some
some differences there also i love that
she says my children are too young to
understand the nuance of this
what's the nuance exactly like really
i'm explain to me the nuance
of men walking down the street spanking
each other on the bare bottom with flogs
in front of children
is there a lot of nuance there that i'm
missing i feel like not but according to
the left
this is nuanced education of children
according to the radical left now
i do want to differentiate again i think
there's a broad middle of the country
particularly i know a lot of gay folks
who think that this is really terrible
that you should not be exhibiting
kink behavior in front of children but
the point is this the radical left which
is basically decided that all human
behavior ought to be treated
the same unless it's religious behavior
that all human sexual behavior ought to
be treated with equal levels of respect
and acceptability
and that children ought to be
indoctrinated into that belief it's hard
to argue against that principle
on the basis of a sort of lack of
fundamental understanding of natural law
according to the washington post's
columnist the kink community has
participated in pride since its
inception
risking their jobs and safety to be
authentically themselves in public it's
all about authentically themselves it's
all about you and we have to
indoctrinate children
to accept your quote-unquote authentic
self and to celebrate your authentic
self so it's not about kids
it's about you it's about you feeling
good about yourself and indoctrinating
kids
in order to not focus on them leading a
happy life but in order to create a
society in which you feel more welcomed
and accepted this is the perspective of
the radical left and they can't feel
welcomed
and accepted unless your children too
participate in the celebration and the
acceptance
says this columnist in the washington
post i agree that pride should be a
welcoming space for children and teens
but policing how others show up doesn't
protect or uplift young children
instead homogenizing self-expression at
pride will do more harm to our children
than good when my own children caught
glimpses of king culture they got to see
that the queer community encompasses so
many more non-traditional ways of being
living and loving as much as i want them
to spend time in queer spaces so they
can be with families like their own
i also want them to know they shouldn't
limit their understanding of what
relationships or expression
expressions look like to their to
whatever's most familiar
i want them to see they can make their
own way in the world how else can they
learn about the scope and vitality
of queer life how uh how delightful
how delightful and this columnist
continues quote
children who witness king culture are
reassured that alternative experiences
of sexuality and expression are valid
no matter who they become as they mature
helping them recognize that their
personal experiences aren't bad or wrong
and they aren't alone in their
experiences i can't think of a more
relevant or important reminder for youth
who often struggle with feelings of
isolation and confusion as they discover
more about themselves and wrestle with
concerns about whether they're normal
enough
including kink and pride open space for
families to have necessary and powerful
conversations with young people about
health
safety consent and most uniquely
pleasure
king visibility is a reminder that any
person can and should shamelessly
explore
what brings joy and excitement see this
is the the problem
with the radical left argument there are
a lot of things that we don't approve of
as a society
uh that i'm sure bring a certain subset
of the population joy and excitement and
they are forbidden by law and well they
should be
by the way sexualizing children removes
one of those barriers but
understand the case that this person is
making is not only
that we shouldn't ban kink at pride
parades it's that it is a fundamental
good
for children to watch kink at pride
parades it makes it makes them more
open-minded it makes them more accepting
and of course we're really protecting
them because you never know
what weird stuff they might be into and
if those kids who are five six
four years old if they turn out to be
into weird stuff which of course would
never be shaped by the environment in
which they're raised of course i mean
environment has nothing to do with this
it's completely genetic
kink is just completely genetic just
like everything else except for the fact
that it's not and there's no proof of
that but
it's it's completely so you don't have
to worry about your kids being affected
because you know they're just going to
be who they're going to be sexually of
course
all of this is designed at the
indoctrination of children
it's designed at the indoctrination of
children and and and
pushing what are behaviorally
abnormal standards on children and then
teaching
those children that the highest form of
good
is celebration of this it is sexualizing
children
and by the way you making like the the
line from here to pedophilia is
pretty straight i mean it's a pretty
straight line from it is good for kids
to watch kink
so that they can explore their own
sexual feelings to why can't they
consent in actually exploring their
sexual feelings with people
i mean why i mean children are sexual
beings too
if you can't see the line being blurred
here i'm not i mean they're literally
talking about children watching
kink parades i'm pretty sure that the
line from their pedophilia is real thin
says this columnist we don't talk to our
children enough about pursuing sex to
fulfill carnal needs that delight and
captivate us in the moment is that
really what we don't talk to our
children enough about
really that's that's what society is
lacking is it is is the pure pursuit of
carnal pleasure
and and speaking about it to small
children who are incapable
either of understanding it because they
haven't even hit puberty yet
or two even if they're teenagers making
solid decisions on that basis
they remove all moral lines and they're
going to live a happier life seems to be
the
predominant notion and again what that
really is about is people want to
express adults want to express their
authentic selves and they want children
to applaud them because they want
everybody to applaud them
that is not good okay i never want my
children to worry that exploring any
aspect of consensual sex or touch
is taboo real again
i'm gonna read that sentence slowly for
you because i don't understand
how this doesn't blur over into
pedophilia seriously i never want my
children to worry that exploring
any aspect of consensual sex or touch is
too taboo
if you have kids you're going to teach
them a lot
about what kind of touch is okay and
what kind of touch is not
but says this columnist if we're afraid
to talk about kink with our children we
prioritize the status quo
and here's the big issue right
sanitizing and censoring their access to
information about appropriate and normal
self-expression
you're damaging the children remember
this is not just i want to raise my
child i want to raise my child which
again would be objectionable because
your child can't consent to how you're
raising them
in a perverse way beyond that i mean
honestly in a in a decent society cps
would be on its way after reading this
column
child protective services would be
headed directly to this person's house
after reading this column
exposing children to men flogging each
other's bare bottoms in public
my goodness okay but that's not the
extent of this the extent is your child
should be exposed to this too
it's that your child is is less and you
are a b you're a worse parent for not
exposing your kids to this
these are the very attitudes that made
pride necessary and life affirming
for so many of us in the first place we
have no business imposing them on the
next generation
kink embodies the freedom pride stand
for stands for reminding attendees to
unapologetically
take up space as an act of resistance
and celebration refusing to bend to
social pressure
that asks us to be presentable that's a
value i want my children to learn
okay well um this is child abuse and um
and the fact
that we as a society have decided that
this stuff is worthy of the pages of the
washington post says an awful lot about
the direction of our society because
everything
that people think is too radical and
far-fetched five years from now becomes
the law of the land
that seems to be the the common pattern
when it comes to social
politics and sexual politics in the
nation
and once again we are going to reach a
point where americans just say no
and they should have said no to a lot of
this stuff
long i mean once it's reached the page
of the washington post
it is my goodness but the blowback is
coming and it's coming strong
and the more the left embraces this
stuff
do it like really i'd love to see it i
think the apathetic middle is not going
to remain apathetic for long when you
start telling them that their children
need to watch
kink parades in order to be more
broad-minded so they will not be judged
because we don't want them to be
judgmental of others and also because
they
the children need to explore their own
kink sides
and the reason i'm spending a lot of
time on this is because it is indicative
of a consistent world view
there's a world view on the left that
says all sexual behavior is appropriate
and decent and good and also
that children should be taught it okay
and
again if you think all sexual behavior
is appropriate and decent and good
then why shouldn't children be taught it
after all in fact the worst thing you
could do is repress
children in a freudian sense this is the
this is the moral battle in which
parents are now engaged and you wonder
why people are moving from blue states
to red states
you wonder why people are seeking to
protect their children by taking them
out of public schools
and not subjecting them to the scrutiny
of state authorities or more and more
thinking
like this parent is thinking and there's
a phrase that my friend eric erickson
has used in the past he says
whatever is whatever is allowed
eventually becomes compulsory
right you will be forced to care
whatever is allowed becomes compulsory
in the end and that is that is exactly
right when it comes to the
social left and its politics you think
right now this
woman is just saying i want to take my
kid to a king parade which is bad enough
eventually be you must take your kid to
a kink parade
because if you don't take your kid to a
king parade you're performing an act of
child abuse and you're undermining
social norms that accept kink behavior
that is the way it's going to go okay
and kink is just an
outer edge example of how this is has
been a mainstream philosophy on what for
a very long time which is we need to
indoctrinate your kids
in k through 12 about the wonders of
lgbt lgbtq lifestyles and lgbtq morality
and the falsity of gender ideology and
we must indoctrinate them now we have to
do the same thing on race
if the left is not it's the left is not
willing to allow you to live and let
live
that middle libertarian perspective it
just doesn't exist when it comes to the
education of children left knows it the
right better get onto this real fast
i think they're starting to we're in a
battle for the culture and for our
values
like and subscribe to help keep our
videos on the front line of the fight
and top of your feed